President Trump is spending the weekend
at one of his golf resorts in Scotland
as he prepares for Monday summit in
Finland with Russian President Vladimir
Putin on Friday hundreds of protesters
demonstrated in Glasgow Scotland second
largest city against mr. Trump's visit
to the UK many said the protests were
against the president not the American
people
there were also protests in London
yesterday and more demonstrations are
planned in Glasgow and London for today
the president is at his Golf Resort in
Turnberry on the west coast of Scotland
south of Glasgow Roxana Saberi is
intermarry Donald Trump has been to
Scotland several times before but this
is his first time as president you can
see how tight the security is here
police officers are lining the edge of
the resort where the president is
expected to spend his weekend playing
golf his visit here follows meetings
with the Queen and Britain's Prime
Minister when President Trump landed in
Scotland last night he left behind in
England a trail of diplomatic
disruptions because I didn't criticize
the Prime Minister I have a lot of
respect for the Prime Minister would you
he backtracked on controversial comments
he made in an interview with Britain's
top tabloid cycle criticizing Prime
Minister Theresa Mays approach to
leaving the European Union whatever
you're gonna do is okay with us just
make sure we can trade together that's
all that matters both leaders focused on
their country's quote special
relationship even holding hands at one
point I would say the highest level of
special am I allowed to go am I allowed
to go higher than that I'm not sure but
it's the highest level of special there
are very special people after his
meeting with the Prime Minister
President Trump became the 12th US
president to meet Queen Elizabeth she
welcomed him in the first lady at
Windsor Castle with a ceremony followed
by tea chatting more than 15 minutes
longer than scheduled the president
largely avoided central London where
tens of thousands of protesters filled
the streets and a large balloon
depicting him in a diaper hovered near
the houses of parliament
at a smaller rally in Glasgow Scotland
demonstrators included Americans like
Jill Porter a tourist from Oklahoma
daily distress local resident Martin
Heaney said President Trump isn't
welcome here he has a racist he is a sex
addict sexist a misogynist he has
anti-gay there is there's such a long
list of reasons why he shouldn't be
allowed to come here but what about the
argument that he's here to strengthen
the relationship between the u.s. and
the UK I think that's totally bogus to
police the protests and protect the
president massive security operation is
underway outside his Golf Resort in
Turnberry
officers are searching cars and snipers
are set up on scaffolding but in a major
security breach a paraglider circled the
resort for several minutes last night
flying within yards of the president to
protest his policies on the environment
President Trump is expected to stay here
until Sunday evening he's preparing for
his first summit with Russian President
Vladimir Putin in Helsinki on Monday for
CBS this morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
Turnberry Scotland